- Last one, B.
- [Gavin] Last one.
- [Daniel] Okay, we're good.
- [Gavin] Whoa!
- Hello everyone, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- We're the Slo Mo Guys and
we're incredibly on edge,
right now.
- Yeah.
I'm nervous.
- Why are you nervous?
- Well, it's not just
because I'm about to jump
into a load of mousetraps,
it's because I don't want
them to go off before I do.
- Yeah.
- This took hours.
- We've spent four hours doing this.
We had a couple of calamities.
- [Gavin] No!
- [Daniel] What even
happened, how did that do it?
Was it the one I was pushing?
- [Gavin] I don't know, didn't see.
But now Dan is ready to
leap from that ladder,
onto the trampoline, full of
I'd assume a thousand mouse traps--
- I think there is about
a thousand we've done now.
- Someone could freeze frame and count.
Let's get out the way.
All right, good luck counting.
Dan, you ready?
- Yeah, I just want to
get on with it let's go.
- Good luck.
- Thank you very much.
- I did offer to do it though didn't I?
- He did, he did.
- I would have done it.
- Yeah, but I didn't want to
mess up the button trigger.
I didn't want that responsibility.
- Oh god.
- [Daniel] I don't think their
could possibly be a jankier
table to jump off.
This is like, horrendous.
- Don't try this at home ladies and gents.
- [Daniel] I'm ready to
go into the mousetraps B.
- [Gavin] Okay. Go for it.
- You ready?
- [Gavin] Yep.
- [Daniel] Woah!
It's in my hair!
- [Gavin] Oh my god!
- God! Flip!
- [Gavin] How was that?
I think they all went off.
- I think so.
- [Gavin] I think they all went off.
- Goodness me.
- [Gavin] It's actually in your hair.
Wait, where did the goggles go?
- I didn't put them on.
- [Gavin] You didn't put the goggles on?
- I forgot!
- [Gavin] You're a maniac.
- No I was too excited I was like --
- [Gavin] Oh god!
- I just sort of closed my eyes and hoped.
- [Gavin] We had them, where were they?
Oh they're on here.
- [Daniel] Oh, I got too excited.
- [Gavin] Did that hurt?
- Well I just got like
little nips all over my body.
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- Wasn't like, anything really painful.
It was actually kind of comfy.
- [Gavin] Ah.
- The main thing was
falling into the trampoline,
to be honest.
I'll just keep this here now.
Ah man, did they all go off?
- [Gavin] I think they all went off.
- That one didn't, let me see.
Shall I see how many of them
need to go off, hang on.
I think they all went off.
Look at that, you can
tell I gave it my all.
That is dodgy.
- [Gavin] God, you almost
Captain Video'd yourself.
- I did what, almost like yeah.
- [Gavin] Look at that.
- I wasn't worried I just went for it.
- [Gavin] That was a
tremendous performance Dan.
I can't believe you
did it without goggles.
- Yeah I know, I was just
like I wanna do it, let's go.
- [Daniel] At this
point, my fate is sealed.
- [Gavin] It's one of those
things where it's like--
- [Daniel] There's nothing I can do.
- [Gavin] It was at this point he knew
You're in, your hands are in, ugh!
You're like going through them.
- [Daniel] All of them have
stayed still and then whoa!
Oh man.
- [Both] Oh my god!
- [Daniel] They all started
from the outside and went in.
- [Gavin] That's so cool, it
looked like a speaker cone.
- [Daniel] Yeah!
- [Gavin] Look at that crumpled heap!
- [Daniel] All flown up in the air now.
Everything bounces back.
- [Gavin] That was tremendous B.
- [Daniel] My legs are still
up in the air still now.
- [Gavin] That was class!
I look like some mysterious
sort of silhouette man.
- Yeah you haven't unlocked
your character yet.
- So I realize I did the
intro wearing a cowboy hat
and I didn't mention the cowboy hat.
Which means the audience
thinks that I thought I
could pull off a cowboy hat.
- Yeah you definitely can't.
- I know, in reality it was
sunny and I was just trying
to wear a hat, and this
is my new favorite hat.
- This is my new favorite hat.
- I'll just pop it down.
That's quite good actually yeah.
- Yeah thanks, yeah.
- I thought that footage was tremendous.
We actually had the perfect
amount of mouse traps
to visualize that sort
of inward chain reaction.
- You would never have
guessed that either.
- Yeah.
- Who'd have thought that?
Because we covered every
square inch with a mousetrap
we could see exactly the reaction.
- And in real time because
I was so adrenaline
and frantic about them
all going off by accident,
which they did while we
were setting them up,
I didn't really pay
attention to what order
it all happened in.
I didn't even see it.
- No, I think afterwards
you pushed the button
and you were panicking
because you were like
have we got everything.
Did we get it?
Cause that was the
biggest amount of effort.
That was probably an hour
per second of footage there.
- That took four hours to set it up
and we recorded for four seconds.
- Yeah so an hour per second.
- Thankfully our camera
can stretch one second into
several minutes.
- Makes it worthwhile.
- Using the right camera.
Woo all right, well that's
quite short and sweet
but hopefully you enjoyed it.
I always like those simple ideas.
They're often my favorite ones.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to the main channel,
we've got a second channel
if you want as well,
and we will see you in the next video.
Which is a slightly special one.
- Hope we trap a good audience for that.
- Trap a good audience?
- Mouse traps.
- Yep, that's good, that's good.